the stories we tell the presentations we
deliver and the slides we share serve to
help us get our thoughts and feelings
across to others
the success of these various types of
communication comes from our ability to
understand others needs
today we'll talk about how empathy can
make us better communicators
[Music]
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business
welcome think fast talk smart the
podcast
[Music]
today I am really looking forward to
speaking with Nancy Duarte Nancy is the
founder and CEO of Duarte Inc a
world-renowned communication consulting
firm Nancy and her team have coached
countless well-known companies including
apple and Salesforce they were
instrumental in helping to bring to life
Al Gore's An Inconvenient Truth which
many claim is the most seen slide
presentation ever Nancy is the author of
six must-read communication books
including slidology resonate illuminate
and data story welcome Nancy I am super
excited I'm happy to be here too Matt
I'm excited thanks for being here let's
go ahead and get started when it comes
to communication coaching you and I are
of a similar vintage we've both been at
this for a long time we can remember
acetate slides and 35 millimeter
projectors I'm curious to get your
thoughts on where we are today in terms
of people's expectations for
communication and the channels that we
use yeah I think people don't have
patience anymore for a presentation not
well done we used to be able to get away
with it because all the presentations
were so bad but now people don't want to
spend their time if it's not bringing
value so I spoke at South by Southwest
someone tweeted I was interesting and 50
people walked in the room well that
meant 50 people walked out of other
rooms so people just don't have the
patience for a presentation where it
wasn't rooted in empathy and the other
thing impacting a lot is virtual or
Blended presenting and you're talking to
technology instead of having eye contact
and it's really takes a lot of work and
physical control almost like you do as a
golfer right where you physically have
to control how you're showing up so that
you come across as empathetic through
the technology those are two really
important things to work on this notion
of being interesting in capturing
interest and being empathetic are really
important and so many different channels
for our communication and we we have to
learn not just to structure our messages
but we have to learn how to interact
with the technology it makes it much
harder I remember just having to print
out my slides and put them on top of the
projector right your overhead
transparency that's exactly right I was
back in the day I know you believe
storytelling is critical to successful
communication and you did some really
impressive Research into what makes for
a compelling story can you share the
insights you found and any best
practices we can follow so we can craft
more engaging and influential
presentations yeah I think uh probably
the root of every answer I'm going to
share is empathy first so and thinking
through sometimes as a presenter we
think we're the hero right we're well
lit we're up on a stage all the
attention's on us but in reality the
audience is the one who if if they don't
leave with your idea adopted your idea
is going to die so you have to really
have an empathy first mindset and then
there's some classic points from story
that you could pick up around presenting
like most presentations don't have a
clear beginning middle and end which is
classic my seminal work resonate was
when I Dove Way deeply into story and in
the process of researching stories I had
right beside me a book called the Hunter
greatest speeches of all time and I knew
that the greatest speeches had a rhythm
and a Cadence and there was a pulsing in
him and I wanted to figure out why and I
figured out that it's kind of this rise
and fall this cathartic rise and fall
that great storytelling has and that's
to get that you would structure your
talk to kind of have this push and pull
between moving people away from what
currently is toward what could be and
you use that as a structural device it
turns your talk into an influential talk
of your time to transform people so you
start from a place of it's about the
audience so it's audience Centric and
then it's really structure and those
who've listened in I'm a huge fan of
structure and what I love about that
work you did of is taking people from
what is to what could be and it's not
just once you do it multiple times and
that's what really drives interest and
as you said leads to influence yeah it
brings that pulsing and that Cadence and
desire yeah can you share one or two
speeches that many of us might have
heard that do that well yeah so so when
I thought I've uncovered this structure
or made this kind of Discovery I knew
that it would be true if it applied to
Dr King's I Have a Dream speech and in
the business context I took Steve Jobs
iPhone launch speech since then I've
analyzed almost 100 of it are in the
hunter greatest speeches of all time and
what I like also beyond having that
structure and using that as a guide
what's so important is we have to look
back at other presentations and learn
from them and I love that you discovered
what you discovered by looking back
because a lot of us just especially in
academic research we're always looking
forward
in the business world the stories we
tell often use slides to help support
and reinforce what we're saying your
book slidology is seen as the definitive
work on the craft at least from my
perspective can you share a few key
takeaways with us how do you create
compelling slides when that was written
the presentation software apps made
really fugly slides by default I mean
fugly so by default everything was
really pretty trashy and so what it did
is it explained what good design was and
my my favorite quote was from John maida
who said wow it's the first time
someone's actually made the business
case for design suddenly when you read
the book you can kind of see why your
slides are ugly and then kind of do
something about it so what it also does
it makes you step back and not think oh
I have to lay a bunch of objects on a
slide it forces you to step back and
conceptualize what might need to be said
so instead of like the classic handshake
in front of a globe because I'm going to
talk about Partnerships teaches you how
to mind map the word part partnership
and your partnership might be more like
two peas in a pod or it might be
opposing Savory things like salt and
pepper it might be Ginger Rogers what is
your partnership like and what's a
metaphor or a concept you can say about
your partnership that would get people
closer to understanding what the
partnership is right so this whole
concept of needing to brainstorm out of
the back out of the box Concepts so you
show up unique you show up different you
show up memorable that's kind of bigger
than just slide making and it kind of
covers that whole gamut one of the key
takeaways from that book is similar to
what we've talked about before is slides
are not for you as a presenter slides
are for the audience and so the creative
ways you're talking about thinking about
Concepts like partnership I recently was
doing something on collaboration and I I
was Googling for images on collaboration
and I found so many handshakes
high-fivings but finally all of a sudden
I got this
peanut butter and jelly ketchup and
mustard and all of a sudden I began to
think differently about collaboration so
I just getting people to think about
slides being for Their audience and not
just a teleprompter and do you need
slides like I think when we update this
book which we're we're working on and
thinking through like we had a
multinational leader of a multinational
company come to us from India who was
going to speak with the CEO of
five brands in the world I could just
say that he was like okay I'm gonna go
meet with the CEO I need five slides we
were like you're going to be in the
CEO's office asking for 100 million put
the computer away and then we just
rehearsed him sketching so he jumped up
to the Whiteboard he just grabbed a
piece of paper he just drew the concepts
and he walked away with a promise of 100
million and he had eye contact he had
empathy the guy could see his passion
otherwise they would be sitting side by
side looking at a laptop and not have
built the camaraderie and credibility
that it takes to really convey a message
the fact that you who is associated with
beautiful wonderful impactful slides
saying maybe you don't need slides is a
lesson everybody needs to think about
you run a large organization that's
focused on communication and I would
imagine you and your employees have a
high bar or high expectations for
quality and Clarity in your
communication internally what are some
approaches you yourself use to better
communicate with your employees and what
techniques do you suggest other leaders
use in their internal communication I
love this question because people ask me
all the time what's the hardest
presentation you've ever delivered it's
like every internal one I ever have to
do because like I can get paid money to
travel and speak and people are like
eating out of my hand but when I stand
up and speak to my employees they know
I'm going to ask them to change in some
way and also as the presentation company
if I don't have great slides I don't
have great narrative and I don't know my
delivery it's like oh my God the
expectations on me is the presentation
lady are just off the charts and so the
call to action always usually involves
like most CEOs don't present unless
there's a call to action that's asking
them to change in some way and so I have
to have a great structure great story
and one of the things that we're really
good at is doing listening tours we do
listening tours we do surveys and we
have a Culture Club and so I have
multiple ways to tap in to the sentiment
I can test early messages about the
change that we're going to be going
through I can get really good feedback
we do an annual kickoff meeting every
single year we do it the week of Dr
Martin Luther King's birthday because
it's I have a dream right so we cast the
dream and the vision for the next year
during that week so we nail the talk
which is usually 90 minutes people get
excited but then we have what we call
shop day that follows it now that we're
virtual it spreads across a few days
like a few hours for a few days and it's
to immerse them in the dream how do I
immerse them so they could see it
through our eyes and we found that when
we deliver the talk and then immerse
them in what it's going to look like
when this dream is realized it gives
them fuel for the whole year to keep
going keep their head in the game I mean
we keep doing the internal comms around
it but just that ability to declare a
future and then immerse them in it
really propels us really far gets get
everyone aligned the thing that strikes
me most about what you just said is that
you spend a lot of time thinking about
your internal comps and I think many
leaders see it as a necessary evil and
something that they just spend you know
just gotta get it done versus spending
the thoughtful time yeah we have a
monthly meeting too and we carve out
half of one of our three hour long execs
to just work on the messaging for those
meetings because they're that they're
just that important so taking the time
being thoughtful I I like how you focus
group and listen tell me a little bit
more about a Culture Club that brings me
back to my youth when there was a band I
didn't come up with the name that they
named themselves that so you know I
heard indranui speak at Cheryl
sandberg's house she used to invite all
these women to her house she said that
out of all of the hundreds of thousands
of Pepsi employees there was about 40 50
of them that actually drove the culture
which was so interesting to me that they
were actual drivers and ones that made
the culture healthy and all of that and
that always struck me which made me
really proud of the fact that we had
this committee it's a little volunteer
army of my strong employees who are the
ones that kind of know laterally across
the whole organization how everyone's
doing and they meet on their own so what
they do is they are the ones who'd come
up with the concepts they come up with
the metaphors they come up with the the
job AIDS the activities and yeah they're
the ones who love and care enough about
the company that they drive that whole
thing what a cool practice and I can see
how that can really empower the
employees but give you insight into what
you should be thinking about that's
great thank you
regardless of how well thought out your
presentations are we often run into
hesitation and resistance how do you
advise people to think about and address
these audience concerns that can come up
the most important thing is to pull
together what I call a skeptic committee
so you come up with people who are
actual Skeptics if you have that kind of
a healthy psychological safe culture or
you come up with people who can play a
skeptic and just come up with some of
the most ridiculous things but and
people actually think those like we
think they're ridiculous but someone
actually feels that way or thinks that
way and so we have people try to put out
on the table every single way someone
might resist every single way someone
might be hurt every single way someone
might entrench and then we put that into
the presentation let's say you're going
to present some data but it's kind of
controversial you have to say I chose
this data set because XYZ LMNOP I
rejected this data set because XYZ you
know and and we need to be really honest
and forthright about what we have chosen
to reject and why so it's not all about
pushing people towards something you
also have to get people to let go of
some things and let them let go of this
data set or let go of this old Norm that
used to be in our culture or let go of
this customer like whatever those things
are sometimes moving forward is a lot
about letting go
that's a really powerful thought that a
lot of us focus on pushing pushing
pushing in the direction we want to go
and yet sometimes it would be better or
we would be better served to focus on
the things holding us where we are and
Sever and sever those things that's what
illuminate was a lot about a lot of
people forgot how hard it was for Steve
Jobs to move people from Mac OS 9 to Mac
OS 10 and literally he was getting
frustrated with the developer Community
he literally had a coffin on stage with
stained glass played eerie music and
held a funeral for Mac os9 it's like Let
It Go it is gone move on and so there's
powerful things and ways you can
communicate outside of a presentation
like a ceremony and that really worked
and the fact that you pull Skeptics
together and encourage people is is
helpful this notion of opening up the
Insight through your culture committee
through bringing Skeptics together I
think could be really helpful I hear
that you're expanding your offerings to
include trainings on listening can you
talk more about the importance of
listening and communication and
highlight one or two key listening
techniques we should all work on WE
contend that building on active
listening this isn't instead of that
yeah make it really clear you're
listening and you know all of the active
listening tools but building on that is
how you respond is part of listening and
even you know part of active listening
says to withhold judgment but what if
the person talking to you wants you to
judge their right what if that's the
very thing they're seeking so two gals
on my team Megan and Nicole did a couple
years of research pretty deep research
and have built an assessment where you
could figure out what your default
listening style is you have one of four
default listening cells we Define
empathy oh look empathy came up again we
need to find empathy as know yourself
understand others and adapt yourself so
it's a little bit more I can't walk in
your shoes if I don't know what shoes I
wear you know myself so that I can step
into yours by the way you have some
really cool yeah I got my grandkids
picked these out for me
so by understanding how you show up as a
default as a listener and then I can
assess you I can understand you and how
you want me to listen I need to adapt so
my default is to advance like I listen
to advance in a close second of mine is
discern well I do that because I'm a CEO
people are coming to me with questions
all the time discern Advance discern
advance Advanced discern and that's just
my modality all the time but there's a
lot of times my exact team doesn't need
that for me one time I was away for like
10 days on vacation Off the Grid which
is really rare came back they were
updating me and they didn't want me to
jump in and say this this they wanted me
to be support them and say good job they
didn't they didn't need me to do my
default so the acronym is said sa ID
support Advance immerse or discern and
those are the four types and then you
may want me to show up in a nurse and
not discern so I need to understand the
situation look at you through a new lens
and then how I respond to you makes you
feel like I listened or it makes you
feel I didn't it's it's powerful it's
changed me as a leader it's changed me
as a mother changed my relationship with
my children it's been really good for me
so well it sounds like it would be good
for all of us just taking a time to
understand how we listen and how we need
to adapt to connect with other people
and people I mean it's all a research
phase it grows sales it helps Employee
Engagement all the things that people
are hurting right now like really
hurting on
it holds the key so it's exciting the
more and more I do the work I do the
more and more I do this podcast the more
and more listening becomes a critical
element and I'm really curious to
getting your answers on the three
questions I ask everybody who joins me
are you up for that yeah all right if
you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would that be so it
doesn't mean I necessarily have a
Mastery of this title but I would say it
is seek first to understand and then
speak
seek first to understand and then speak
so that's a that that's all about
empathy yeah but the seeking part seems
to be to be even more active I think I'm
working on staying curious and staying
really curious and not showing up
thinking I know and so that's why it's
seeking to understand that's really
powerful and I agree it's a much more
active and the fact that you have to be
curious first
question number two in this I'm going to
be really fascinated because you have
worked with just some amazing
communicators who is a communicator that
you admire and why my favorite
communicator on the planet is Scott
Harrison he is the CEO of Charity water
and he started this non-profit years ago
he's like a clubster in New York has an
existential moment when he was on the
mercy ship seeing small children drink
filthy water what he does he's his use
of story and how he communicates and how
he reveals information over time is
unprecedented I it he just weaves it so
he's got the master structure and can
weave story in so elegantly and he tells
personal stories like one of my
favorites moments was when he had been
doing it for 10 years and he was even
getting numb you know you can you can go
to Ted in these conferences eventually
it's like you just have to get to a
place where it rolls off your back so he
had kind of lost this own like fire he
felt the his own fire so he went out and
sought out a story he traveled back to
Africa because he'd always rumor of a
story that was really tragic about this
gal seeking out water and he went and
found that story and re kind of gulped
that story in again in it and it gave
him the emotional energy to keep going
sounds like wonderful work he's doing
and wonderful storytelling and and he's
keeping himself immersed in it what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe well
you probably would guess the first one's
empathy
and incorporate story story framework
story structures and stories into it
like plant little stories throughout and
then also your delivery so how you come
across it either diminishes your
credibility or amplifies your
credibility and so just make sure that
you're coming across the way the
audience wants it now when I say
delivery I don't just mean Stand and
Deliver an eye contact and maybe the
best thing you could have done is send a
slide doc a presentation to read ahead
and they don't even need to meet like
delivery is expansive it could be a
video could be sent a video so it's
delivery also kind of means the medium
and not just your body language and
stuff like that so empathy and listening
story and structure and delivery and
really thinking about the medium very
very helpful well Nancy this whole thing
was helpful and I really appreciate you
taking time and sharing with us how we
can all be more empathetic curious and
Powerful communicators thank you it was
fun to be here Matt
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
Stanford GSB